é perguntei se o henrique chamou de
farsa porque ele viu correndo uma vez a
única vez que eu corri na minha vida
depois que eu entendi que era não
contador de histórias a saque
bom pessoal eu vou falar pra vocês um
pouco da minha experiência no foco boa é
um projeto que nasceu em julho do ano
passado é e honra muito aqui e agradeço
de antemão também o henrique é o diego a
guilherme também pelo convite
é um prazer a gente assiste muito ted e
para nós é uma satisfação estar aqui tão
boa não vou compartilhar essa
experiência e é uma é um peso bastante
grande seu primeiro porque eu corro o
risco de ser atropelado pelos grandes
palestrantes que vem depois que deixei o
bigode é só pensar eu era gordinho de
bigode beleza
eu mesmo bom pra começar a quem é que já
fez um frio a pintura em algum lugar do
mundo levanta a mão
é muita gente sugiro que vocês comecem
puro pelo piloto em porto alegre que é o
melhor né então vocês vão conhecer o que
há de melhor nessa prática um fim ou
quinto é uma é uma prática que nasceu na
europa com a idéia de mostrar as cidades
para as pessoas de uma forma
descontraída
geralmente são jovens que fazem isso é
bastante estão vindo bem também
são jovens que fazem isso de uma forma
não acho que tava valeu ainda tático é
que eu não sou mandona então não estou
muito acostumado com esse tipo de coisa
são jovens que fazem isso de forma enfim
normalmente não é um emprego é uma coisa
que eles fazem em outros turnos da sua
vida e juntam grupos é gratuito ao final
a pessoa daquilo que acho que valeu a
experiência então é uma coisa que vem
mudando a forma de fazer turismo e vem
transformando talvez os turistas em
viajantes
então acho uma coisa muito legal
acho que tem empresas fortes por trás
que costumam vender outros tipos de
passeio
mas enfim é uma coisa que vem crescendo
bastante a gente montou o capô tentando
importar esse modelo no início é claro
uma forma voluntária também porque todos
nós temos nossas atribuições do dia a
dia
e aí a gente começou e começou e se essa
história de um jeito muito engraçado né
a gente foi passar um carnaval juntos eu
e um amigo thiago que é um dos
fundadores do projeto e foi sensacional
pelo carnaval porque vamos passar eu ele
ea namorada dele né então nessa nessa
ânsia de achar coisas pra fazer pra de
ocupar um pouco ele falou cara é vamos
fazer um filme à altura ele tinha morado
na europa e tinha feito alguns a gente
fez no chile um grupo pequeno eu ele ea
namorada dele e uma lituana e foi super
legal ea gente foi evoluindo essa
conversa na omd onde as boas conversas
evoluíram mesas de bar e foi indo foi
conversando e um dia eu comecei a tentar
mexer em programação de site comecei a
fazer um site vizinho testando o modelo
e mandei para os amigos decide avisar
que era teste e aí no fim do dia tinha
várias pessoas perguntando quando sair o
primeiro filme que não sei o que
eu posso ter um problema
marquei para duas semanas passei o tempo
suficiente de léo e pede a e convidei o
tiago cristiano para serem os meus
parceiros e aí saímos é na verdade essa
foto do 2º passeio primeiro pensei foi
tão surreal que nem falta gente tirou
era um sábado de chuva no inverno sair
museu
o tiago cristiano dois anos um casal de
amigos a e duas senhoras foram embora na
metade
a gente estava com um adesivo colado no
peito que obviamente caiu com a chuva
foi sensacional e esse é o segundo é e
photoshop mais profissional e claro tem
a chave de novo ele o dinheiro ea sua
esposa
lucas que virou depois voluntária do
projeto levou os pais também
vocês vejam que o negócio era bastante
caseiro com o passar do tempo
a gente foi evoluindo foi descobrindo
quem eram as pessoas estavam indo é e aí
a gente realmente deu uma
profissionalizada que dá pra dizer isso
e hoje a gente já fez mais de 50
parceiros já caminhou com mais de 1.100
pessoas em 30 países diferentes
a gente tem o facebook bastante
movimentado e é considerado hoje no
tribunal vai ver que é a principal
plataforma de viagem sair atrás o número
1 em porto alegre
passamos o museu da puc essas
recentemente então para nós é um prazer
muito grande a gente tem 51 avaliações
49 delas cinco estrelas e duas quatro
estrelas está procurando quem são os
dois graças a dados que deram quatro
estrelas sacanagem bom e aí vem a parte
talvez mais curiosa de toda essa
história é quem faz essa brincadeira
começou com três
andré eu caso cristiano e tiago e já
antecipou um pouco meu currículo sou
publicitário de santa catarina
o que um publicitário de santa catarina
está contando histórias do porto alegre
enfim recebendo turistas
pois é mas fica pior fica pior porque o
segundo membro ele até gaúcho até gaúcho
mas é engenheiro
mas calma fica pior ainda porque o
terceiro também em dinheiro e não é nem
gaúcho é de concórdia
imagine um publicitário até tem né
aquela trabalho é um pouco mais a
comunicação mas engenheiro contando
histórias depois é aí a gente resolveu
dar uma amenizada no negócio e chamou
dois caras de porto alegre que funcionam
a administração é porque a gente estava
perdendo muita gente quando acabava a
apresentação a gente engenheiro de
concórdia sair a 50% do grupo e chicago
só nossa
então assim a loucura começa aí são
caras que não tem nenhuma grande
acadêmico ram e um pouco nessa linha de
alta de data também de buscar
conhecimento em outras fontes em livros
e revistas em lugares diferentes para
poder trazer coisas novas pessoas e
claro a gente foi melhorando os
engenheiros foram aprendendo a se portar
em público
o passeio evoluiu aqui uma foto
dentro no início desse ano então já não
tem só amigos já são bastante é bastante
mais pessoas que estão ali é e ea gente
começou a perceber um sutilezas que
quase a totalidade nosso grupo era de
pessoas que tinham alguma raiz com porto
alegre ou moravam lá ou era de lá ou
moravam para estudar o time fazer
intercâmbio é então ou seja essas
pessoas de alguma forma conhecia a
cidade o conheciam a sua história mas
superficial
então a gente não podia dar a eles
aquilo que um fiel ao que tanto normal
da europa que é aquela formação
histórica mais normal assim um cara que
não conhece nada a gente precisa escavar
coisas diferentes para poder dar
praticar uma experiência diferente a
gente foi se adequando e aí eu passei
foi crescendo
a gente começou a fazer um roteiro num
evento com o célebre senhor baixando a
figura clássica
vocês podem ver que o grupo cresceu né e
são outros roteiros
a gente fez bonfim também foi o primeiro
roteiro que a gente pensou para cinco
pessoas falarem para cinco voluntários
falarem e esse na cidade baixa
foram mais de 120 pessoas então foi uma
loucura nunca façam isso é
definitivamente não é não é muito
saudável mas enfim ali a gente aqui
mostrou que a gente está no caminho
certo ou seja a gente deixou de ser um
passeio e passou a ser uma experiência
na cidade ou seja o cara tá a gente está
correndo com um cinema com um parque com
o pôr do sol no guaíba
porque a gente deixou de ser
simplesmente passei pra turista passou a
ser uma atração da própria cidade então
é a gente tem que cuidar disso para que
ela realmente entregue aquilo que ela
promete ea gente realmente tem tentado
fazer isso aqui a gente fez um passeio
especial da feira do livro semana
passada muito legal que a câmara do
livro nos convidou
aqui o passeio do dia do rock com música
ao vivo contando sua história do rock
gaúcho também encheu de alegria
aqui a gente entregou o lançador zinho
de ouro para o nosso milésimo walker
então essas coisas a gente começou a a
agregar o passeio ea gente pega as
pessoas desprevenidas
porque elas vão pra ouvir histórias
acabam voltando com amigos para casa
acho que essa é a grande diferença a
gente não tem pretensão em fim de ganhar
dinheiro com isso a gente não tem a
pretensão de que isso se transforme na
atividade diária a gente tem a pretensão
de que a pessoa saia de lá melhor do que
ela entrou e ela realmente tem uma tarde
divertida então a gente fez amigo
secreto ou seja com os casos vão são
desconhecidos e fazem amigo secreto é
sensacional é fácil pequenininho que
vinho eles atividades que propiciam esse
lado mais humano e aproxima uma pessoa
da cidade eu acho que isso é muito legal
e as pessoas realmente se apropriam do
projeto saia do projeto querendo mais
ajudando indicando viram defensores e
isso é muito bacana e nos deixa muito
contente a gente imagina que está
caminhando pelo caminho certo
uma das grandes mudanças que a gente
teve nesse trajeto todo foi sacar a
diferença entre história e história
como vocês perceberam a gente não tem
nenhum degrau de acadêmico nem de
história e geografia além de turismo e
arquitetura
então seria um pouco pretensioso da
nossa parte querer com dar uma aula de
história da pessoa que vai lá então a
gente não faz isso
a gente resolveu contar a história ou
seja buscar fatos curiosos que a gente
gostaria de contar para amigos
a gente tenta fazer isso de uma forma
bem natural e tem dado muito certo acho
que essa foi a grande mudança um exemplo
aqui do que a gente é faz é o palacete
malakoff alguém que conhece palacete
malakoff guilherme você já foi o fiel
que não vale
ninguém conhece o palacete malakoff ele
foi o primeiro arranha céu da cidade de
porto alegre
ou seja lá em 1870 e 1880 a gente não
tinha uma porto alegre muito é vertical
era uma cidade bastante enfim casas
baixas e tal
o palacete malakoff então foi esse
primeiro grande a primeira grande obra
de engenharia
o grande hotel da cidade quando as
pessoas chegavam de barco conseguiu ver
duas coisas à distância as torres da
igreja das dores e o palacete malakoff
mas mais legal do palacete malakoff era
seu apelido era o verde
minozzo malakoff porque o vertiginoso
malakoff porque quando as pessoas subiam
no seu último andar era tão alto que as
pessoas ficavam realmente convertir as
damas botavam a mão na testa ficavam
tontas
os rapazes bombeavam a perna porque era
uma sensação única ver a cidade lá de
cima lá do alto ver as pessoas
caminhando formiguinhas
eu vou mostrar pra vocês para ser
titular koff está cortada a foto de si
mesmos e gloriosos quatro andares com o
térreo
então essa foi uma das primeiras
histórias que a gente botou no passeio a
gente viu que dava uma relação legal
porque olha só isso aqui é mais legal do
que falar sobre história política coisa
que a gente não tem domínio tão grande e
poder incluir isso é muito curioso esse
prédio ficava na praça a 15 de novembro
no centro e muito perto do mercado
público e nos anos 70 foi destruído e
construir um prédio que é cinco vezes
maior mas com certeza não tem a metade
do carisma do nosso grande vertiginoso
malakoff a e acho que o que entra no fim
a e da reflexão é um pouco a essa
dicotomia de perfeição versus realização
tem um cara que chama verzoni em porto
alegre que ele é um cara que adora
poderá sim mas é uma coisa muito trash e
impressionantemente as pessoas gostam
mas mesmo assim e esse cara me ensinou
um dia conversando que a gente não pode
ficar preso a perfeição do projeto não
pode ficar agregando muita coisa pra que
ele saia do papel é voando baixo na
melhor da sua do seu formato
na verdade a gente vai com botando tanta
coisa tanta coisa é tão difícil tirar
ele de lá que ele nunca vai ser perfeito
na verdade nunca vai ser feito mesmo que
o tira de lá porque sempre tem alguma
coisa que pode melhorar
e aí o que a gente resolveu caminhar
sobre o lado da realização o que não
importa se ter um sábado chuvoso
se não tem ninguém lá citou camiseta
colada com adesivo o que importa é que
tu vai fazer um negócio com amor e com
muita muito carinho eu acho que é isso
que faz a diferença essa imperfeição que
você queria
nada e aí o pessoal que vai perceber
isso vai agregar vai ajudar e aí
naturalmente aquilo vai evoluindo
eu acho que é isso a gente conseguiu
fazer muito bem
é eu coloco aqui à porta desses caras
primeiro porque eu amo eles é e segundo
porque eles ajudaram a fazer essa
imperfeição eles foram os caras que
olhar antes era um cara esse negócio é
tosco mas tem futuro
o plano tem futuro para nós e abraçaram
aquele negócio que era o rio eu mesmo
era o primeiro passeio deve ter sido um
péssimo mas ele garante ser um puxa que
legal e foram lá fazer uma última
reflexão que a gente vive hoje numa vida
em uma sociedade enfim não é restritiva
então a ponderada no sentido de prever
erros de não querer a muito falhas e
acaba amarrando demais as nossas coisas
é errar menos não significa acertar mais
e errar menos significa no máximo que
tentou - é e eu acho que a gente pode
pensar quantos livros a gente poderia
escrever quando os projetos a gente
poderia tirar do papel quanto os amores
a gente poderia viver
se a gente deixar se levar por um minuto
por aquilo que bate no nosso peito
então é eu acho que eu diria que é
montado um gráfico e dado o meu nome pra
ele mas não consegui
mas imaginem que a vida da pessoa é um
tapa montanha russa cheia de altos e
baixos mas a gente o nosso medo e com o
nosso favor de erro agenda tanto ela e
ela acaba ficando desse tamanho
ela vai passar numa rua estreita que o
cara vai vivendo vida toda
nota 7 nota 7 e meio vai passando em
tudo por média
e aí é isso é realmente é muito ruim
porque o dia que a gente perceber que é
nos segundos nos minutos que a gente
fura esse espectro e que a gente tenha a
coragem de viver a vida na plenitude
são esses minutos que fazem a vida valer
a pena a gente vai ter uma outra
compreensão sobre a nossa existência e
eu acho que eu queria agradecer a vocês
porque esses minutos aqui com certeza
fizeram valer a pena minha existência
muito obrigado o henri wallon que meus
amigos estão aí ea todos vocês tenham um
bom dia